ok
en fait c'est juste un truc bête c'est
que ce clip qui dure trois minutes et
demie ouais
et pendant ce clip il ya vingt personnes
qui meurent du sida un jour je veux dire
ça mais c'est c'est en fait ces espèces
de de choses dedans fin de médicaments
qui est la trithérapie a fait croire que
c'était fini tu vois ce qui fait que ça
s'est arrêté c'était plus à la mode le
sida donc en fait c'est grave qui a
plein beaucoup de gens qui meurent de ça
et là toujours pas de vaccin et voilà
donc c'est en fait c'est un appel aux
dons il faut faire le 110 ha oui 710 il
s'en dit ce qu'il faut faire pour pour
qu'ils aient de l'argent quoi c'est ça
va commencer le week-end du sidaction tu
sais le 1er 2 3 avril et voilà voilà
c'était juste ça donc vous dire tu a
multiplié les jeunes
bien